[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
good afternoon we are here today to pay
tribute to the first women of Yale
College 575 trailblazers who came
through Phelps Gate in 1969 and changed
this university forever this is where we
find a fitting place to honor them to
honor you we've chosen the spot because
it is where many Yale students
historically have begun their yell
careers as they move into old campus and
it is where they march out onto the
world in midst music and banners and
cheering crowds following commencement
and this is not far from where the first
building of the Collegiate School in New
Haven now called Yale was raised over
300 years ago in this place rich with
Yale history we remember that every
barrier broken is both an end and a
beginning the first women of Yale
College inaugurated a new era their
legacy is all around us in classrooms
and in residential colleges in the lives
of distinguished alumni and in the
nation and world
they helped shape now it is represented
on our campus today with the dedication
of this 50th anniversary commemorative
stone we honor their courage and
commitment we remember their spirit and
resilience your spirit and resilience we
thank them we thank you for being the
first as we join together with students
faculty alumni and staff here and around
the globe
we look with
to mizzen to future generations who will
like the extraordinary first women of
Yale College carry-forward yells mission
of light and truth into the world and
now it is a great privilege to introduce
my friend Elizabeth Alexander a 1984
graduate of Yale College a prize-winning
poet essayist educator and scholar miss
Alexander is the president of the Andrew
W mellon Foundation she is a former
longtime faculty member at Yale where
she was the inaugural Frederick
iseman professor of poetry and the chair
of the African American Studies
department she received an honorary
degree of letters from Yale in 2008
please join me join me in welcoming
Elizabeth Alexander is it is a privilege
once again to welcome you back home
[Applause]
thank you Peter
it is such an honor to be here and I
know we want to see what's here but I am
very honored to have been asked to
deliver some real remarks so it'll take
a minute but it's a beautiful day mm-hmm
meditations on co-education I've been
thinking about the difference between
evolution and revolution evolution moves
forward in unfolding time and over time
the organism changes there is all the
time in the world to catch up that's
evolution revolution is a sharp turn and
about-face occasioning acceleration some
things need to be done decisively and
happen fast sometimes places and people
and ideas need to be jolted forward into
the present tense so the organism can
continue to grow and flourish both have
their time place and utility
omitting undergraduate women to Yale was
the revolution that brought this
institution forward the rest has been
evolution but first the university
needed to take a sharp turn into the
future the first classes of women to
attend Yale those women that we honor
with this celebration were tough stalked
and bold to use the words of the poet
Robert Hayden seeds had been planted
earlier with women who were pioneers in
the graduate schools like Pauli Murray
and Grace Hopper I have always felt
particularly inspired by Otilia Cromwell
the first black woman to earn any degree
from Yale and the first black woman to
earn a PhD in English anywhere in 1926
her example in history have always felt
proximate to me because since careers in
as professors in schools like Yale were
not open to black women in 1926 she went
on to teach at Dunbar High School the
renowned black academic high school in
Washington DC where one of her students
was my beloved grandmother Winona
Logan I grew up being trained and
corrected in my language and grammar and
reading habits by my grandmother who
attributed every rule to Otilia Cromwell
mm-hmm
she has been memorialized by Smith
College where she was the first black
female undergraduate and indeed Smith
College has an entire Otilia Cromwell
day though I dare say miss Cromwell
would disdain the fact that on that day
there are no classes and here at last
there are not one but two portraits of
her just making sure it sticks there
isn't a lot on her in the Alumni files
but we do have her dissertation and
combing the Alumni files for any sense
further semblance of the woman is a
letter that she writes on October 5th
1922 to the Yale Athletic Association
requesting two tickets for the
harvard-yale game if I may have the
privilege of buying tickets she wrote
will you send me an application blank it
is noted for alumni records that she
became a member of the board of
directors who would have charge of what
was called an encyclopedia of the Negro
a project undergone by W EB
Dubois from 1939 forward her name is
listed in a special card file that I
have seen with my eyes a card labeled
Negroes who attended Yale and in other
places on the record she's identified as
colored while studying in New Haven
Cromwell lived at 65 Edgewood Avenue and
a letter that she wrote to her father
summer of 1922 gives a wonderful
description of graduate study but also
of a savvy woman scholar making her way
and to read just a little bit while I am
back in New Haven where at least the
nights are cool after hot days I have a
large room facing west with three
windows in the mornings I work in the
Yale library which is a quiet roomy
place in the summertime in the
afternoons I work in my room that is at
present while I am making a general
survey of my subject and it is possible
to bring enough reading material home
from the library to occupy me for
several hours later on when my work
becomes more detailed involving a
ceaseless verification of opinions from
many sources I shall be compelled I
think to do all of my reading in the
library although I am not absolutely
certain I shall not know for sure until
the department approves I think I shall
work on some phase of Elizabethan drama
from many points of view it would be
more comfortable to select a subject
relating to the Negroes but two
difficulties stand in the way the
improbability of my being able from what
I know of the possibilities of the field
to get something that would be big
enough for the kind of book I've got to
write and more importantly the fact that
any work which I might do in that line
would be absolutely independent because
naturally I'd know more about it than
any of the folks here in one way the
independent work would show a certain
kind of power but on the other hand my
main object in being here is to learn
scholarly method and to benefit by
scholarly criticism most of all I want
the work I may do in the years to come
if years are granted me to be critically
sound I am glad that I have a sense of
values ambition for place or fame is not
my
setting folly I wish to do work that I
like time to keep unambitious writing
someday that aspiration and making a
place for herself in a place that was
not supposed to be her place is what the
women we celebrate today did years later
in community I am proud to have arrived
as an undergraduate in 1980 in the wake
of this first generation with their
revolutionary example lighting the way
when my classmates and I arrived it was
incredible for us to think that the
first class with women had graduated
only a few years before to ground us in
that moment 1980 Yale didn't have a
woman department chair until three years
before we came nor female Provost nor
female president of course women rhythm
played its first concert when we were
undergrads the women's sports team
captains pictures were first placed on
the walls of Morrie's in the 80s the
Women's Studies major was approved our
sophomore year despite the fact that an
English professor submitted petitions to
the faculty referring to it as quote the
department of gross Ness that is true
revolutionary changes beget natural
evolution you don't know when you set
foot in a place if you will belong to it
for the rest of your life when you meet
someone and are enchanted and even when
you come to love them you cannot know
who will be there for the long road you
cannot know how the self who enters a
place and comes in and then out the
other side is changing emerging becoming
her self you don't know which places you
will forever belong to even the most
venerable and solid institutions the
most resource and tradition-bound are
not static I love that I could for
example as a Yale English major of any
given decade could do recite from the
first lines of the Canterbury Tales and
that I could do it together with many of
you and reach back centuries we won't do
it right now but we could do it right
now but here's the point we belong
we took those words into our bodies we
held them we said them we believed them
as we took joy in the mastery of memory
we are all impart those words but we are
other words to other rituals other
common denominators we are not one text
we never were we belong to an evolving
entity that believes in the strong spine
of certain traditions but also evolution
Yale has changed you have helped change
it it will continue to change Yale was
our place to learn from to demand from
to shout at and of our school I have
seen it evolve lucky to come back and
teach for fifteen years and see amazing
young people full of brilliance and hope
and challenge and Verve who knew because
of the path-breaking work of this
generation that they were at an
institution that had survived
revolutions and evolutions and that it
was their responsibility to be part of
that dynamic process and I am also proud
right now to have my own two sons my
feminist sons studying here unable to
imagine that they ever could have gone
to school without women or been taught
only by men or not read books by all
kinds of different people they literally
can't imagine it
so Yale men today are feminists too
I think that evolution is truly possible
when we understand that this place that
was not founded to educate the majority
of us is our place to together out of
all of our experiences we are one alumni
body and even though we have had moments
where we've been on the cusp of huge and
uncomfortable change this place is ours
I think that one of the most important
things I learned as an undergraduate at
Yale that has guided me through my life
that I feel that from this generation
these sunflowers I learned is how to be
a productive outsider at a place I was
inside of the gift of being marginalized
is that you have to see kaleidoscopic
Lee the gift of being marginalized is
that you always know who is not in the
room and how precarious membership can
be that gift teaches that bringing
others into the room is our
responsibility however we may find a way
to do it and so for the sunflowers the
classes of 71 72 and 73
I hope these few days have been
beautiful I hope they have been full of
somatic remembering feeling the first
tiny cool undercurrents of fall in new
haven tilting your heads just so to look
up at the tops of these buildings in the
sunshine turning right or left by
instinct when you enter various
buildings being glad that there are now
more bathrooms that you can go into
thinking about the good and the bad of
it the glory and the struggle the
vaulting force of what it feels like to
burst into a new stage of your own
development in a place that never leaves
us to which we belong and to which we
will hopefully all keep coming back as
citizens we weren't taught by enough
women but we were taught by legends like
Sylvia Arden Boone and Murray bore off
we didn't read many books but written by
women there weren't enough of us in the
classrooms at the time
but you all came here and you left your
mark and you learned and you took that
learning out into the world and you
changed this place and you left your
name's metaphorically and now literally
on the walls and on the on the ground
learned what it was to change an
institution and help it revolve you've
evolved as part of your responsibilities
and I believe it took a revolution to do
that I want to close with this short
poem by Muriel Rukeyser one of the best
poets I know on evolution revolution and
the carefully observed small moments
that make history and this poem is
called painters in the cave with a long
ago Flair a woman stands her arms up red
twig black twig brown twig a wall of
leaping darkness over her the men are
out hunting in the early light but here
in this flicker one or two men painting
and a woman among them great living
animals grow on the stone walls their
pelts their eyes their sex their hearts
and the cave painters touch them with
life red brown black a woman among them
painting thank you very much
[Applause]
[Applause]
thank you in September 1969 the first
women undergraduates arrived on campus
with spirit and determination these
women of the classes of 1971 1972 and
1973 transformed life and learning in
Yale College
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]